-Now I thought I'd share some of
my favorite worst-advice-ever
stories from you guys.
This first one
is from @RoeyCustard.
-Mmm!
-She says...
That's not good.
This one is from @MrPibb4life.
He says...
Well, that's --
That's not -- That's...
That is not --
That's bad advice.
-That's false.
-That's not true.
You know it's not true.
-Yeah, the Navy
should know that.
-It's true.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @kinkyturtle.
She says...
-Well...
-What are you cryin' about?
-The paint's gone.
-Technically, it worked.
This one's from @d nnykingsl y.
-Ooh!
-Rather.
-Where's he from?
-Good day to you, sir.
-Danny Kingsley.
I don't know if
that's how he talks.
But Danny Kingsley.
He says...
Third-degree burns all
over his stomach.
-Are those freckles?
-No, they're not freckles.
They're scars.
They're grease scars.
That's bad.
-Turpentine will
get those out, man.
-Thanks for the advice.
You know my doctor --
Dr. Pepper.
-Yeah. Dr. Pepper.
-Yeah.
This one's from @canadianlinz.
She said...
Tell me about Casual Friday.
I'm really excited to work here.
I'm a people person.
This one's from @To neo71.
He says...
No. That's bad advice.
That is bad advice, dude.
Oh, my goodness.
-No.
-This one's from
ScrangelaSaurus.
She says...
Where do I see myself
in five years?
Taco Bell.
This last one's from
@liz nawrocki.
She says...
Oh, wow.
That's bad advice.
There you have it.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.